[Music]
[Applause]
let we get to Andy Staples he covers
college football for at on three Sports
he was at the Ohio State Michigan game
on Saturday and he'll be at the SEC
Championship with Alabama and Georgia
sorry to put you through that Andy um
who had a worst month Jim Harbaugh or
Ryan day oh Ryan day no question because
Jim Harbaugh not being on the sideline
Saturday made losing even worse for Ryan
day because you already you were already
0 and two in your last two against
Michigan now you're 0 and three and
you've ALS lost to the interim coach who
by the way if something happens with Jim
Harbaugh down the road Chiron Moore is
probably the coach so that's the guy
you're probably dealing with going
forward and Ryan a has got to get it
figured out I I was there in 2019 when
Jim Harbaugh was on loss number five in
road to Ohio State and he's being asked
all these questions and he can't answer
him Ryan was in the same position on
Saturday it was Eerie same stadium same
lack of answers okay if I said in the
next three years who was more likely to
still be at their school Ryan day or Jim
Harbaugh oh Ryan day no question that
that's an easy one because Jim Harbaugh
has tried to go to the NFL the last two
years clearly there's still an itch
there and look he was really good in the
NFL he got to to a Super Bowl he went to
three NFC championship games so would
imagine that that he still would like to
try to win that Super Bowl uh also there
is the matter of two NCAA investigations
where the punishment hasn't been handed
down by the NCAA yet so we don't know
what's going to happen with that Ryan
day he's got time to work this out now
if he gets tired of everybody yelling at
him because he wins all the other games
except Michigan he could go somewhere
else but I I do feel like and from
talking to people around Ryan day he
wants to work this out he wants want to
make this work and and I gota be Hest
Dan when that 12 team Playoff starts
next year Ohio state is perfectly built
for that because they're the type of
team that's going to get in every year
and if they get hot they'll win the
national championship so Ryan day is
actually still in a really good position
he's just got to figure out Michigan but
can he survive next year at home losing
to Michigan Maybe not maybe not that
that is that is the thing because John
Cooper went 210 and one against Michigan
there was no social media only nerds
knew what the internet was like this is
a completely different environment I I
think if 0 and four might be enough to
push them over the The Edge and Ryan Day
understands that because like he he
makes it very clear that game is more
important than everything else everybody
knows that and yeah he's got to get that
figured out but if you ask me the same
question even if he lost that game the
Jim harbar Ryan day question I still say
Ryan day is more likely to
be help me understand what's going on at
Colorado with Dion s ERS and his
recruits so he he's had a couple
decommits of late uh he came out and
said they're not going to be an ATM
which was the wrong thing to say Dion
you know he has this platform that he
can offer which should lead to good nil
money as well because there's nobody
else who can make people watch the team
play like Deion Sanders can but when you
say we're not going to be in ATM that is
coach speak for our Collective has no
money we're
broke and he went on his radio show
clarified say oh we got you need to help
our
nil yeah you're gonna have to do that
because they need offensive defensive
lineman those people are the most
expensive players in the transfer portal
they're the most expensive players
coming out of high school other than
quarterbacks like I always laugh because
before nil started I I'd get these
questions uh from from readers and they
say well what's going to happen when the
quarterback makes all the money and the
left tackle is not making I'm like dude
the left tackle is going to make a ton
of money yeah it will evolve to be just
like the NFL salary scale and it has in
just two years yeah I think that's
interesting I remember when somebody was
talking about that uh you know George is
getting all of these defensive linemen
and uh Texas A&M was spending a lot of
money on defensive linemen and I said
yep yes that's how you build a team you
build it from the inside you're going to
get a quarterback but if you have a
great offensive and defensive line
you're set you're good to go and I I
understand that these guys go for pretty
penny right now I was just surprised
that Dion sounds so modern but then he
sounded so old school when he said we're
not going to be an
ATM I said on my show last week Dan I
was like when did dabos Sweeney land in
Boulder like it it's because like dbo is
old school he's stubborn he he's not
been willing to adjust to things and
you've seen a drop in performance in
Clemson Dion doesn't need to be acting
like Dabo he just started doing this he
needs to adapt to the world as it is now
it's not going to ever go back to what
it was in fact it's going to go the
other way where the coaches are going to
make less the schools will be paying the
players directly that's going to happen
in a few years the court system is going
to force them into that but right now
they have this weird backward ass system
where you can give Tom Allen a $15
million buo which by the way he was nice
enough to negotiate down from 20 so
Indiana was willing to pay $20 million
to fire Tom Allen well why would you
just use that to buy better players like
it's a stupid system but that's where
we're at right now it's the sort of the
middle ground between what what was
before and what will be it's a transfer
portal season what should we be keeping
an eye on keep an eye on those offensive
and defensive linemen because they're
they're really hard to find and they're
starting to realize their value uh
there's a a New Mexico offensive lineman
named JC Davis who entered the portal
today and everybody's like who well he
was maybe the best offensive lineman in
the Mountain West so guess what
everybody on Earth is going to want this
guy so if you haven't heard like last
year there's this guy named Johnny
Cornelius who played at Rhode Island and
when he entered the portal his phone
just melted and he want he's the
starting right tackle at Oregon he'll be
playing for Oregon in the Pack 12
Championship Game on Friday now so that
that's what it every we're all going to
look at the quarterbacks everybody's
going to look at the shiny thing look
over here look over here most of the
quarterbacks in the portal we we assume
it's going to be like cayb Williams or
Kyler Murray Most of the quarterbacks in
the portal are in the portal because
they were not going to start at their
old school some of them might be trying
to move up to a different level of
competition or make some more money but
most of them are in there because they
were not gonna start yeah but you look
at Michael penck Jr you look at Jaden
Daniels you look at BO Nicks those the
guys are you know all transferred and
they're all mentioned in the Heisman
race exactly but they were all having
issues at their old schools Michael
pennick was was injuries and everything
Bo Nicks was you know on the outs with
Brian harson so yeah if you if you see
an extenuating circumstance then that's
the quarterback you probably want
because it's probably not about the way
they play but watch these offensive and
defensive linemen coming from the FCS
coming from the group of five because
what they've realized is they are a very
valuable commodity now and there's gonna
be a lot of schools after them I felt
bad with the you know the state of the
Pack 12 it was a great year for them and
it's a shame that they can't build off
of this what is the future of the Pack
12 I mean it's not going to be the Pack
12 as we know it the name remains with
Oregon State and Washington State and I
I love what they've done legally to try
to make sure that the the the 10
departing schools don't just take all
the money like I think Oregon State and
Washington State should get all the
money that's sitting there because
they're the ones who got left behind but
what we're going to see ultimately is a
basically a quasi merger between those
two and the Mountain West I would call
call it the pack whatever whatever
number it is because The Branding is
better but it'll it'll basically be the
Mountain West good to see as always have
fun Alabama and
Georgia oh can't wait what if Bama wins
does Georgia stay in the top
four that's the big question Dan because
Alabama is the ultimate agent of chaos
remember Texas has a head-to-head
winning Tuscaloosa so if Texas wins the
Big 12 Alabama beats Georgia that's
going to pull because remember Texas
might get left out even if they win so
that may pull Texas up and I'm telling
you nobody with Pack 12 teams Florida
State nobody wants to be judged against
a 12- one Georgia because Vegas would
favor a 12-1 Georgia against everybody
and the committee members if you gave
them truth serum with a 12-1 Georgia
you'd say would they beat these teams
they' go yeah probably so you don't want
to deal with that like everybody else
wants Georgia to win Alabama is the
ultimate agent of Chaos
thank you Andy good to talk to you as
always thanks Dan Andy Staples covers
college football for uh at Onre Sports
always makes us smarter there